so welcome back to the 15th ever episode
of the iced coffee hour with special
guest
shelby church and uh even more exciting
news than that we have made so far on
the podcast
29 hundred dollars
nice congratulations guys and uh even
better than that
jack is now uh eight for eight
first options trading for a total profit
of 200
200 dollars i don't even know what that
means eight for eight
probably a good yeah yeah oh the eight
for eight that just means i've been
successful
in the green eight trades in a row he
tries to make one percent right
on that i wouldn't say it's a guess it's
it calculated
so it's basically heads or tails and
he's guessed correctly yeah yeah yeah
yeah so he's one times in a row
so next time would be like one in ten he
tries to make one percent
on every single trade okay yeah yeah
i've watched a couple videos on the
options stuff and i'm like
this one this is a little over yeah you
could explain that midway through the
video we'll have to explain that
i could explain options if we if we're
running if we have plenty of time left
okay yeah definitely notes yeah options
okay great
but this is going to be a really
exciting episode you don't know this but
this is a confronting
shelby church video because you posted a
video you posted a video
how much you spend in los angeles
remember that one yeah and then i
reacted to that one yes
now for those that are not aware you are
a youtuber
can you tell us for like 30 seconds a
little background
sure okay so i've done youtube for like
10 years
and i do lifestyle tech
tesla videos since you pretty much
convinced me on that like i was like
yeah
maybe you're like get it like it'll pay
for itself
sure enough it did yeah so
thank you elon for that yeah so listen
to graham guys
but did you buy tesla stock or no i did
you did but i sold it at like 700.
700. i know it just seemed crazy it just
seems
because i bought it when i bought the
car at 200. yup
that's what i did yeah so i was like
what there's no way it's gonna keep
going
as wall street bets would say you have
to have diamond hands
cannot sell that's one of those stocks
that for me i bought in thinking it's
either gonna i'm either gonna be like a
multi-millionaire from this stock alone
really or it's zero yeah i didn't you
buy like 20 shares
no i bought uh how much did i buy in
like 10 grand worth it like 260
something like that and then i oh wow
yeah but i kept buying in afterwards so
i bought a little bit more
but uh the average buy-in i think was
like 272
268 like somewhere around there but
that's great yeah right yeah
right and then it bought more i think at
14
but more at a thousand so have you sold
any
uh not since i sold initially i sold
half of what i had at 9
14
so you've been doing youtube for like 10
10 years yeah wow
ridiculous amount of time i think so i
was like 14 when i started making videos
i was making videos about makeup and
stuff and i like didn't even really know
what i was doing
yeah it was just bored you know i feel
like a lot of people started that way
and now it's i never would have imagined
that it's like
as big as it is so you never went to
college do you ever do that i went
for a year i went to orange coast
college in orange county
so when i was in high school i did a
dual enrollment kind of thing
i wanted to go to film school like
chapman or usc
yeah and i didn't get in there but i was
like maybe if i transfer
so i went to orange coast college for
basically a year like a year and a half
and i pretty much only took the film
classes and then i was like youtube's
going pretty well
this is what i want to do anyway you
know so and
how many subscribers or how popular were
you at the time of dropping out
um probably like six or seven hundred
thousand
that's a decent amount yeah that's
that's a really decent amount
yeah i could live off of it like when i
graduated high school i could already
live off of youtube but like in orange
county probably not in l.a
wow that's just cheaper so how much were
you making that's that's let me guess
for 4 000 a month yeah i think it was
about that
three or four that's incredible
especially when you're
what you were like 17 18 at the time
yeah when i was 18 i was like this is
awesome
wow yeah so back then what did you spend
your money on
then yeah like after like when i moved
to california
i guess yes i feel like i spent a lot of
money just on camera equipment
just because i thought it was fun to buy
new stuff new lenses
i guess rent there um
i i don't know i feel like i spent less
like so much less than obviously
because i had less but like living in la
i feel like ubers and
brunch like things that i know you're
like whole foods
yeah this is great sweet greens
did you see my reaction video to your
video
i watched some of it but i was like
i was like i don't know if i should
watch it it's not that bad
yeah it's not it's no no it's not
terrible it's not terrible
yeah it's seen worse he has seen worse
yeah yeah
see i thought because i had you in the
end i was safe
i wasn't gonna get no one's safe nobody
is safe
you were safe for like eight months
right so i thought for eight months
never gonna
yeah you posted on one of the weeks
where i was so busy
and there were so many other videos that
that one just got lost in the shuffle
and then i realized like i came back to
that video being like wait a second i
missed out on this one
and now that's probably one of the most
popular
yeah so it's like how many hundred
thousand plus views yeah
which is huge for the second channel
yeah yeah
okay okay yeah most for the second
channel are about 150 so this did more
than double
most viewed video in the past 24 uploads
yeah
yeah yeah how does that feel
good i guess 300 000 people care about
how much money you spend at whole foods
that was the
that was one of my biggest critiques
yeah see i didn't get to that part
it was the whole foods this whole foods
uh postmates was a big one
i thought it'd be postmates because i'm
like back then i didn't even grocery
shop that much
so i felt like whole foods was doing
something right
no trader joe's trader joe's
yeah so much more affordable expensive
haircut
oh you have a haircut 400 425
that's the color the cut is probably not
probably under 100
but the color takes like five hours why
i don't know it just is like to lift
that dark color here
yeah to this color just takes a long
time to just leave the paste on for a
really long time
the paste yes you could tell jack is
into hair
he specializes in this when he's not
options trading
he's learning about uh about hair
but you couldn't find someone who's just
300 bucks see i'm scared like if they
mess up your hair
it is part of your image yeah like you
have to live with that for a while like
if you mess up the color it will
fry it and i don't want to take the risk
okay
fair enough so how much are you saving
now can you give us some statistics or
some figures or some percentages of
how your budget has changed did you
learn anything from the
how much i spend in a week video when i
made it
yeah yeah i mean i was like i definitely
spent i like
i didn't really calculate i don't spend
that much on food and stuff
like it really when you add it up
um i mean i'm saving more with the
quarantine like
gym membership not really ubering
as much kind of thing not traveling
yeah i don't know i don't like track it
as well but i feel like like i don't
know a percentage i would have to look i
use the empower
app okay i'm not familiar with that no
no yeah i did a brand deal with them but
i love it
huh yeah okay i took it up do you think
you're saving enough
or do you yeah i do okay i'm definitely
saving way more than i spend like
a ton more that's good that's why i
don't track it otherwise
if i was like worried about it then i'd
be like okay like
okay yeah what are you saving for well
me and my sister are trying to buy a
house in palm springs okay
i think i she posted a video on that
right probably yeah millennial life
crisis
yes that's i think she posted about it
yeah so we bought a house in seattle
actually like a year ago
ish but we want to buy a house in palm
springs and rent it on airbnb
and then also just use it for fun
actually interested to know your
thoughts on that definitely we'll talk
about that
yeah do you think people if you if you
publicize it that they would want to
stay there just because it's your spot
and they could be like i stayed in in
shelby spot
probably i mean i even if they don't i
think airbnbs and palm springs do so
well they do
yeah it wouldn't really matter yeah but
i also think like
i could do so many videos about it like
we've looked at
we toured some places and there was one
we actually put an offer on this week
but it's just so crazy like everyone's
like
cash offers above asking how much was it
it was 660 and it needed
a good amount of work so we were gonna
make a bunch of videos like fixing it up
and my dad's pretty good with that stuff
so he's going to come
so fun fact no it's not really fun it's
sad
but the home renovation videos don't
really seem to do that well for some
reason
yeah it's shocking consistently every
single time i post a home renovation
video i know i tell jack like listen
this is gonna be a 10 out of 10.
there's no saving this video and sure
enough it's a 10 out of 10. yeah
it's just not a lot of people are
interested in that but some people are
very
are obsessed with that
and all they want is like i want more
update videos where is there another
update
like a week later like when there were
the update video like it probably looks
horrible still it takes time
yeah but uh the other thing with
renovation videos is that there's not a
lot that's done in the beginning like
day to day like you could go
look at it looks the same for weeks on
end and then the last week it's like
every day it looks different so you get
not a lot of content it's it's hard to
click bait unless things
go wrong but you don't want anything
because no nobody cares like we're on
schedule we're on budget we're
we're under budget here it is nobody
they want to see like
over budget guys like the contractor
slipped and fell
now now it's an issue here's what's
going on does that happen like
every time you're renovating like
something goes wrong yes
um so just actually not not honestly not
every time most of the time okay but
minor stuff it's it's like uh
you get into the walls and you realize
well you may as well upgrade some of
these things behind the behind the walls
now an extra five grand
or the floors are out of stock so now
you gotta pick something
two dollars a square foot more expensive
and like little things like it's not the
end of the world but it it adds up
that's what usually ends up happening
and then it's like people don't show up
that's that's the other most common
thing what like the contractors just
don't yeah
oh oh yeah you got to be really like a
manager
in a way i guess my sister and my dad
have had that issue they're renovating
an airstream
and the welder just ghosted he's just
gone
yeah and i just thought that was so
weird like
that's your job yep no well the thing is
a lot of them are so busy right now
okay what they'll do is they'll book
like three different projects knowing
that there's no way they can complete
all three but it's better just to book
them and you lock them in
and then they can kind of you know just
work on whoever's the most urgent at the
time
yeah so you already paid them or no no
usually
usually what they'll want is the work
like the first few days out of pocket
and then they'll demand
that you pay them then plus a little bit
more to buy materials or whatnot and
then they can continue that's usually
how it works you never pay anybody up
front
okay cool yeah because yeah you pay them
up front and they you're gonna
take their time they're priority lists
no
i'm like that was a mistake but yeah
yeah yeah well that's exciting i think
buying a house would be a good thing to
save towards
yeah i mean we're ready to fully like
we've toured a bunch
it's just like waiting for the right one
to pop up because we're very specific
on the one that we want and just when
there is one it's like
it's just they're going for so much more
then even a couple months ago we were
looking but we were waiting for our
taxes
and everything to be yeah yeah so how
does that work when you buy it with
your sister do you both get your credit
run you're both on the title you're both
on the loan too
yeah okay and so why don't you buy one
in your name and then she buys one and
her name
we could buy a better one together i
don't think so
i think i bet you have enough to qualify
easily for a loan in your name because
here's what's going to happen here's
some real estate advice
when you co-sign on a loan it's you you
both are equally responsible for that
loan so it doesn't matter if you don't
pay or she doesn't pay the loan's got to
get paid yeah so they count that against
both of you
so now when when you go and apply for
another loan they're going to look at
this one and be like okay you have this
line a chance that it's going to make
some money so
you could probably show that uh but
still for purposes
of the loan it's going to go against
both of you so typically if you
if you trust each other enough it would
be better you get one in your name she
gets one in her name
i mean and you just have to have an
agreement in writing
separate from that that like you'll
split the profits or something are you
doing it more so for
an investment or are you doing it just
because it's it would be fun
more an investment but i feel like my
sister thinks more for fun and my
parents definitely think
for fun because they're like yes seattle
sucks in the winter
we're going to palm springs i'm like
we're going to be renting it out
yeah but i feel like it would really
come in handy though for
just going for a weekend maybe festivals
because people
trash them for that so i'm like i don't
know oh yeah i don't know if i'd rent it
out for like coachella um
i've heard some horror stories some
family friends have a rental there and
that just gets crazy then i bet yeah so
where else do you invest
besides i invest in stocks and
okay yeah so i think i talked about this
in a podcast
but it's just with a financial advisor
and then i do robin hood just for fun
okay what are you what are your favorite
stocks
well let me take a look i don't know if
you need the financial advisor i've
always said it's like
so either actually pushing a few buttons
how do you know how much they cost
is it a percentage or is it like one
percent i think no
that's a lot that's an absurd amount if
you're paying one percent that's like
the highest of that like hedge funds
don't even charge one percent
okay so this one i feel like i started
this
when i was like 20 or 21 and i was just
so
intimidated by it all you know i was
like i don't want to lose money
doing this and it was like a
friend's dad's friend who was
really good at this stuff i don't know
so it's like okay i'll just start with
that
but i have more recently thought because
i've watched so many more videos about
it and like
yeah i don't really think i need a
financial advisor no
do you know what they're investing in
i've gone on and looked and it's like
so many different things oh wow okay so
and
like some of them are international
whatever like looked it up and it's
i don't know like i compared it too to
the s p 500 and i was like
i feel like it's just about the same
yeah yeah
most of the time all you need to do is
just an index fund yeah
and that has a management fee of point
zero four percent
some of them are even free fidelity
three is viewed right oh
that's true 0.03 and fidelity is free
just nothing you just buy into this fund
and that's all you need to do
what's the catch the catch is that you
bank now with fidelity you have your
investment with fidelity and they hope
that you're going to use
other services now what fidelity is
doing right now is really smart they're
trying to get millennials in with the
zero percent uh index funds hoping that
one day millennials are going to have a
lot of money which i have a feeling at
some point they will
and then they're going to be using other
services you're going to go through
fidelity to get loans or anything else
like this
and then they'll make more money in the
back end but it gets it gets the foot in
the door that's really what it's for
yeah okay so i feel like i should
probably do that yeah i would i don't
think you need a financial advisor it's
it's simple enough for just
one index fund vt sacks um
or whatever the fidelity it fizzrocks is
the fee
fee f-z-r-o-x
is the ticker symbol that's the one to
get fizzrock's that's the fidelity
free index fund okay i'm gonna check
that out yeah that's all you need so
yeah i feel like i should be paying to
go on this
podcast like we could start trying
virtual advice we could yeah
we may as well still be our sponsorships
today
yeah how much cash do you have on you
that's the cost
how much is your venmo balance then uh
we'll just we'll just call it even after
that
that's fine yeah all right well that
well that's good what are your favorite
stocks though what's on rob
okay on robin hood i just really play
around on this
okay let's see do you do any crypto on
it
actually yeah like barely okay is that a
thing for real yes
okay i i just bought like the normal
bitcoin
but like barely any like i really it's
like i only put like three thousand
dollars into this like
all right can i see it it's really just
for fun yeah go for it okay so what do
we got
here i kind of want to tesla okay so
here you know i'll put it right here
yeah so you do own uh a little tiny
0.049
percent of tesla okay i recently did
that okay so you got
uh delta is that downtown delta
500 bucks right yeah that's actually
pretty good all right
disney's a great one yeah uber has been
doing crazy spotify has been doing crazy
yeah i got that right before it it like
jumped a lot so i was like okay
google that's great i think it's really
important to invest in the in the
company that pays you you're gonna have
one share of apple after the split
because you have
a quarter of a share oh perfect so yeah
nice and even
yeah yeah amazon okay look at that
you're up 56 bucks today
there you go so we we've accomplished a
lot now yeah that's yeah you'll fire
your your financial advice you don't
need that uh buying real estate
i wanted to ask about uh the boat would
you live on a boat
god no no you glorified it so much
oh yeah that was a great we reacted to
it did you see it and that was
almost a 300 000 view video as well yeah
you got to keep opening up content like
that
it's fun i just react to your content it
always does well
yeah cpms are high too really it's
probably higher than mine
probably we should compare okay i mean
that i mean can we do it from the phone
i think so let's see we'll compare cps i
want to know too how long it takes you
to edit some of those videos
too long so yeah so my video my reaction
283 000 views
uh wow look at that a 50 audience
retention
that's really good um 2 300
okay so i have a 43 audience retention
people care more
what okay they care more to watch you
react than the actual video okay so
it's about a 10 cpm basically so oh
really yeah
no that's 280 based off of your
monetized playbacks
right right like so 280 000 views got
2400. okay the other one i think was
is that the boat one or is that the boat
one okay one mine got
1.5 million views it made 8 300.
yeah mine's higher yeah wow i think this
your channel just gets like
oh this is a finance channel millionaire
reacts is in the title
yeah and then your reaction video three
here's how much i made from
tons and tons really so 356
000 views this video did so well and
then
i'm kidding forty two hundred dollars
yeah
it did it's way so well so i've made
that
yeah so i've made yeah four or five like
almost seven
thousand dollars off of me off of you
that's not bad okay let's see
seven thousand so i've made like twelve
hundred jack has made some money on that
see jack's made 100 bucks now
okay mine made yours made four thousand
mine made like
just under four thousand wow for six
hundred thousand views yeah and the
crazy thing is just the amount of time
that i know you spent making that video
you know
how many no and you just sit there and
react like
that is what annoys me i'm like why
don't you do reaction videos
i just i don't think me reacting would
do that well
try it i didn't think well i'll
seriously all you got to do that would
probably have a higher cpu as well you
know what would be funny is title of
video my response to graham stefan
i wonder if that would do because it's a
bit of a risk with with your channel
because your audience is used to more of
like a lifestyle i think i think maybe
if you said that they'd be like
what is this i don't like this direction
yeah we'll see
so you'll have to try it if you did that
um just my response to your grandson go
through my reaction video and
react to me reacting to you yeah i think
after a while it becomes so ridiculous
and then i can make a video
responding to shelby church yeah and we
can
just keep going yeah yeah just forever
this is why people start like internet
beef
and stuff like that because it works so
well yeah yeah we'll just start some
beef and
both exactly deal so respond to me i'll
respond to you
and then you figure out like we'll do
another confronting yeah yeah
i'm confronting you
and yeah i like my response too better
than confronting my response too
tends to do well yeah yeah okay whatever
just better i mean i'll trust you on
that the tesla thing
i don't know it works i feel like you
have like the golden
touch whatever with youtube so i'm like
okay yeah for now
we'll see yeah we'll see but your videos
are done really well like how long would
you spend
editing um probably
15 to 20 hours editing a video
maybe less i would have to actually
time it because i feel like i'm a really
fast editor but i just
i add so much b-roll and random stuff
i'll edit half the video and be like oh
i should go shoot more
and i've thought about it i'm like you
sit and talk and people are like
loving it and i'm spending so much time
it's so inefficient
yeah but i like how they turn out i i
agree um
do you reuse b-roll shots i was curious
about that
okay yeah cause there's a few shots that
i saw of you like walking down that
bridge in santa monica
and like a few other randoms have you
reused that yeah if i'm editing and i'm
like
oh i don't want to drive all the way
there and get it like if i have
something i can use
i will sometimes just as a filler too
yeah and i'll get it later if i have
time
but if i don't it looks good i'm like
whatever most people haven't seen
every video right i actually want to
know this how do you plan out your
videos do you script it all out ahead of
time and you know like i'm gonna do a
b-roll shot here
or i'm going to be like do you do you
have an outline that you follow like
that
not really i have like sort of an
outline but it's not like
a script and i'll have ideas and i'll
shoot
about half of it i'll usually like
interview someone or
whatever i need to do for it and then
i'll edit it kind of rough cut it
together
and then i always get way more ideas
after i see it on a timeline
and then i go shoot more and then i edit
more
yeah yeah yeah yes but it turns out so
much better
i plan out everything and then i figure
like which
areas i'm going to be filming in so i'll
like do my outline and then i go through
my outline i figured like okay this is
at the desk this is
chair this is sitting over there this
will be outside and i figure out from
that and then i just follow the outline
i film every segment at once
and then i just splice it together on
imovie but yeah i found this be nice
it is it is it's very nice
but uh yeah i it was actually it was i
don't know if you watch
meet kevin yeah i actually do okay
stimulus updates but don't watch those
but i'll watch them like renovating a
house okay okay some of the stock ones
too
all right so those are the videos that
no one watches for him except the people
who really care the stimulus ones are so
random i'm like what
the views everyone loves the simulation
yeah this is the old post he'll post
like a stock market investing video like
a really well researched video
that like an expert would be posting
might get
a 50 000 views stimulus update yes 600
000 years and it seems like he uploads a
lot
yes multiple times a day but that was
something that i learned recently from
kevin was that like he just
churns out these videos no editing just
talking clear value tax
is another guy doesn't even do a
thumbnail and every video is just
stimulus updates and news update with
the date
600 000 views of video okay that's it
and so i'm thinking well does editing
really matter that much
even for me it's like not i don't always
watch the video i listen to it
so sometimes i feel like i could get
more content out there that people want
to see just by scaling back a little
bit on the editing probably for that
topic if it's something people like are
dying to see
no matter what i feel like then it
doesn't matter yeah but some of my
videos i'm like
this topic's kind of random i'm gonna
have to try really hard to make this
interesting
like really go for it with the b-roll
and everything
yeah so try reactions
that's that's the golden opportunity
trying to mental block of like
putting that little editing in i'm like
there's no way people are gonna watch
well you can throw in little like
random things yeah a reaction is gonna
be the easiest thing you're gonna be
sitting down just have be sit down in a
good location with some cool like
background or whatever
and just have an honest reaction that's
it that's all you gotta do and just as
you're talking throw in some like some
shutter stock images that's what we do
with with the with the water stamps
still on them yeah
okay like literally there could be like
four pixel images
any changes it's funny it's funny like
sometimes netflix
the lower quality is just funnier yeah
yeah
yeah it's more relatable because it's
honestly it's like we throw this
together in
imovie yeah yeah so do you still do real
estate
or just youtube now mostly youtube so
for real estate like as an agent
i mostly refer out all that business um
to mary in the office and someone
actually commented i mentioned that in
one of my videos and someone was like i
can't believe you're giving the deals to
mary everyone gives the deals to mary
and i'm like wow you watch the show
um but yeah no i give them i've been
giving them to mary for quite some time
uh and then as like an investor i'll
just represent myself
okay that's so interesting so you're
just like like youtube more
yeah i love it but not only that just
like for how much money
i make on youtube versus now as a real
estate agent yeah it's just
like just for your efficiency i would
lose money
if i spent a day selling real estate
it makes sense it's not way more on
youtube yeah right
but i was even doing a showing the other
it was i think about a week ago
um for a past client and i was getting
anxiety
showing houses yeah because it's been a
while no
okay because i was just like i have so
much work to do
and it's it you know traffic getting
there traffic getting back
every showing takes a little bit longer
than you think yeah and i was getting
excited like i have so much to do like
how am i gonna make up this time
and just it wasn't worth it it seems
like very time consuming just with
how me and my sister have looked at
houses and i'm like that sucks for the
real estate agent we have to go
look like four or five and maybe we
don't like any of them
and then that's or like if the market's
crazy how it is now we haven't even
gotten one yet
yeah so much yeah i have a newfound
respect like when you start looking for
yourself for the real estate agent like
how much time
some of them not all of them some of
them are bad but some of them just
really put in the time and i i hate
people
like keeping people waiting so yeah
that's that's something for me
can you talk to us a little bit about
the podcast yes
okay so me and my sister have a podcast
millennial life crisis
off of her vlog channel so she had that
vlog channel when she had like a quarter
life crisis
and she didn't she had a quarterly
crimes what is that real yeah
i mean not like anything crazy
but just she moved from la back to
seattle and was like
thinking about working somewhere instead
of doing youtube when it was already
going well
it was just this was like a few years
ago okay but she was just still going
with the name
okay and we wanted to do a podcast
together and could not i mean we were
like that's a good name we'll go with
that
it is a good name but i'm like i don't
feel like i'm having a millennial life
crisis quarter life crisis but we do
talk to people if they have had that and
just kind of it's like the theme
touching on it but yeah it's i feel like
the podcast is fun
but i always forget how much time it
will take to edit
you don't edit it right that's why i got
a jack
that gets a podcast yeah yeah you need a
jack yeah you should get an editor
15 to 20 hours is too much time yeah
find yourself a jack
seriously i was doing everything myself
and uh jack started taking over in the
second channel how did you find jack
email i reached out to him oh that's
gonna be the best
because you know like he's gonna
actually care oh
i got a fun i'll i'll tell the story
this is like our first date story almost
jack sent me like seven emails he was
one of those
he was like i didn't i didn't respond
and it's like
i know you're still there there's a
response and he's seven times
and there was one week or like one night
where i was so overwhelmed we got a
facebook group
and what what i do is that people have
to put in their email address in the
facebook group to get access to it and
then i just need someone to copy the
email address
and then let them into the group that's
all but when you get like
thousands of requests i was doing this
all myself so i'd sit there watch tv
and this like sit there but for hours
and i needed someone to do it i could
not find
anybody who would do it jackson was
boring boring
but i've even offered concealer i was
offering to pay people in the office i'm
like hey if you have spare time would
you do this and they just never have
done it
uh so jack emailed me and i saw this
email i'm like okay why not so i think i
called you
okay right yeah what was that like
getting the call i mean
so you well you you responded to my
email yeah and i
i i the thing i sent back was just so
stupid i was like oh my god my heart
skipped a piece
like something yeah like maybe not
verbatim that yeah something like that
and then he was like all right like i'll
call you or whatever because i sent my
phone number
and then he called me i remember the
first thing i said
when i picked up the phone because i
didn't have his number yet he called me
and he's like hey this is graham
and i was like oh my god i was like oh
uh hello how how are you and it was just
it was a hectic conversation but
but i explained it to jack what he had
to do in this facebook group
he's like don't worry i'm on it i don't
think that was even paid or anything
like that
this was just like a test to see like
this yeah
you said i'll pay you yeah it doesn't
know okay so jack did this
and it was a big thing for me because he
would have access to that facebook group
and all the people's emails so like i
could see that he sent seven emails
seemed like he could string a sentence
together like this is
someone fine he did it all that same
night wow
whereas no one else was doing that so i
was i was like okay if you want to keep
doing this
and then we met up i think for dinner um
and we met and what was oh and then that
was kind of the birthing of the graham
stefan show
yeah i explained yeah i explained that i
wanted to do phone calls but i didn't
have the time to sift through all the
emails and pick the people for the phone
calls
and i asked if jack want to do it
perfect so we started
doing that he started editing those
videos they taught him how to use imovie
did a great job and then now recently
it's full time
yeah so this has been like a while a
year over a year
over
people do but sometimes it's like
it's got to be the right person if
they're coming to your house and
everything i feel like
yeah sometimes like i don't know but
yeah i was looking for someone a while
ago weren't you yeah did you find
anybody a bunch of emails yeah
i actually did find this girl who was
good who i was just in seattle and she
was
out of town she goes to usc okay but
they're like online now
so i'm like perfect you can come work
for me
so i think is she okay she's doing that
it's dangerous if she's in college
that's it's not good that she's because
jack was in college and i got jack to
drop out yeah there's a recent
development yeah
that's what i gotta do yeah you gotta
find the price for her to drop out of
school and just as long as you pay that
price
she'll drop out of school whoa or find
someone who just graduated
yeah i feel like it's you got to find
someone who really likes youtube
and like really understands yeah if you
find someone that's willing to drop out
then you know that they're like yeah
yeah like
quit after a couple months no yeah
because i feel like part of part of it
for me was like you
you can't just work with anybody who's
like all right all internet four hours
later
people who are really into like
filmmaking the style is different
it just doesn't work it's gotta be they
have an ego about it too they're like
you know what if you want to find
somebody who's willing to do a full
because here's the thing jack was was
doing
half college online half this and it
takes time i mean you could explain it
your experience doing that
it was miserable like half college half
work yeah like it was
just so much work yeah yeah i don't know
that's what you did for a while and then
graham was like
yeah the spring quarter oh i started i
started by joking about him like
drop out of school but i was serious
yeah um and then
when he's like all right i gotta go to
school i'm like no no no no it's okay
all right no you're staying here because
i i it was just for me i got
like so efficient now at like what i'm
doing yeah going
back like something would have to be
missed out on
yeah and it's hard to i feel like if you
find the perfect person
then it's so worth it like if i could
have if my sister didn't make videos and
just
worked for my channel that'd be perfect
like i want someone who's better at
shooting or editing than i am
but usually i'm like we could reach out
to anybody
if you want we'll put your email it's up
to you we can put your email address in
the description you're gonna have some
okay so for anyone who's interested you
have to be local
uh no college or willing to drop out and
you could work out whatever payments
really
slack with college like you're in it but
yeah something like that
and and who gets youtube because
everyone who watches the pod like is
super into youtube
yeah they have to
especially this far in like if you get
to this far end you've already you've
already
passed the first test so already we've
weeded out probably
i don't know fifty percent of the people
probably about that so there we go
special offer
and an interest in like actually using a
camera
yes that's good you'll make more money
too if you hire it out
i know because there's more you could do
i mean that's really what it comes down
to
yeah i just get so like perfectionist-y
on my videos
i'm like i feel like i can't have
someone else okay so
i admit to that and on the main channel
i do everything
but for me i was rushing out the videos
on the second channel for the reactions
because i just didn't have time so i'm
like i got two hours i just got to knock
this out
jack will spend like five hours editing
the same video yeah and make it so much
better
because he puts in all like the cool
like all the zooms and stuff that i'm
like oh it's not gonna make that big of
a difference
he'll put in the work to do that and it
does make even a marginal difference
if not on that video the next video in
the video after that okay so i can
definitely do that for a second
yeah you should do an income breakdown
video
of like my yearly income yeah your
streams of income yeah
why why haven't you done that i've done
like adsense
for the year for last year no sometimes
for brand deals i'm like
you don't have to mention per brand deal
yeah no you just get you give a
blanket and for sponsorship i always say
for sponsor you can't tell exactly how
much it is but overall
it's added up to blank i think you
should do that that would be another hit
video for you yeah
yeah and then you can make a video how
much i made why that makes me way more
nervous
why because like adsense
i don't know it's like less right and
then brand deals i feel like people are
like what
i think it's it depends on how you spin
it if you're like yo what's up guys
so here's how much money i made you
throw the money down yeah
it's different if you do that then like
here's how i started here's the
progression and you show videos of
yourself like you know 10 years ago
here's how i started here's how i built
this up
and you talk about in detail like every
source of income and you break it down
and then you give the total and you'll
be like this is 10 years worth of work
you guys can do it too something like
that is it's inspiring to people
yeah i mean i've always had a good
response
on the ones that are like this is how
much i made i feel like rarely are
people because everyone feels like
youtube they could kind of do
it which is true and
so it's not as bad so maybe i will i
need to like calculate it for the year
for 2020. i would count well do you just
do it so far for the last like eight
months
but come up and just title the video i
don't know what what was the one that i
did
how i created seven sources of income
that may generate
x a month or whatever it is just do
something like that i think would do
really well
i don't have as many like random streams
you'll think of a whole bunch
of income a whole bunch true okay yeah
once you start getting to the
nitty-gritty like amazon affiliates
yeah march merch no merch
okay i don't have a course i don't do
that stuff
all right so you're going to have a few
how do i build five sources of income
oh we built one source of income force
you'll think of other little things what
about uh like patreon
you know patreon what about this the
join button
um i haven't on youtube i haven't really
okay
i've thought about doing a video
actually except now it's not
the best time to do it where i rent my
car out on turo
yeah because i don't do really well in
there
like before i bought mine i rented this
guy's enturo
and he was like oh this is my second
tesla i just rent it and he makes
more like renting it or something that's
a great video idea let's
let's do that before she does it yeah
i'm kidding i'll do that tomorrow
no i would not though right i wouldn't
yeah you can get like
actually insane i wouldn't actually do
it because i would be looking over that
and be like that scratch was not there
before
where is it going i couldn't do it and
isn't it weird like you could see where
they are on the app
you could see where they took your car
i'd rather see it
i mean it doesn't no i feel like i'd be
worried about where are they
are they i'd be checking it non-stop
yeah yeah your thumbnails have gotten
kind of crazy but we have so
much fun on thumbnails we have so much
fun i feel like some people think that
we do
uh them unironically but some of them
some of them are definitely ironic
they're purposely over the top some of
them
yeah like the blue yeah
it works it does yeah we have so much
fun
some of those we're joking we're like
we're laughing so hard as we're doing
these stuff because it's
fun yeah and i'm like how outrageous is
this but let's try
it yeah and we try it and then like
people some people don't like the thumb
but overwhelmingly people do
like the thumbnails yeah i think people
know it's like that's youtube too
yeah everyone's gotta play the clickbait
game a little bit
the fire is my favorite but now
everyone's yeah it's just like we have a
thumbnail all prepared it's all perfect
everything's ready graham's like what do
you think about this and then we like
look at each other like should we add
flames
should be
it's funny it's true though it's always
like maybe we should add flames to yes
but now everybody is doing flames so so
the issue is that you catch on to
something that works
yeah everybody starts doing it and then
it stops working everyone now is like
smash the like button
i've noticed that and it's annoying
it bothers me because it's everyone's
doing it now so now you have to be like
you have to
take that to the next level how do you
because now i've been saying like
obliterate destroy the like button make
it
oh make it turn blue and then everyone
else like make it turn blue
oh yeah so i gotta think of something
else so on today's video i
because you have to now like keep
pushing it uh today's video was
sponsored by
the like button so i said okay instead
of
having a segment here sponsored just hit
the like button
because that's free and that helps with
the channel so there you go i just saved
you 60 seconds
i hate that everyone's doing it though
i'm like i know surprise i don't press
it on anyone's videos
you should though you are part of the
problem though yeah okay
you are the 90 of people who don't know
i'm like
i'll be like like it if you want i don't
really care
if because for like if you're watching
this hit the like button i just feel
like it
i don't think it makes that much of a
difference it does i think the proof
is in the pudding it makes a big
difference on the videos the more
engagement you get the better
plus it's like if it helps you right it
it makes like
a difference in a video like i have some
videos that i've done so well
where i had i forgot to add tags or
something where i'm like yeah i agree
some of that's random stuff doesn't
matter i don't know it's like thumbnail
and title yeah i 100 agree with that
graham it can't hurt though the like
button thing yeah yeah i agree but
also something that's really funny is
like sometimes graham when he uploads
his videos
like for some reason youtube puts on
korean subtitles and
every single time it does it graham is
just like are you seriously he's like
this is going to throw off the algorithm
it's going to ruin everything i get
subtitles i get upset because it's their
automatic system they categorize like
every
it's always every time i mention the s p
500
every video with the sap so i think it's
something with the s p 500 that youtube
categorizes it as korean subtitles
in my mind uh youtube would be less
likely to recommend that video in
america because they believe the video
is korean
i mean i could see that yeah yeah so
i've had some videos in the past that
did not do well some videos did
yeah with korean subtitles but there's
no way to change it there's nothing i
can't go in and like
you know put english because it
automatically it's just building up a
card this stock
yeah so now my go-to my strategy has
been i put my videos as unlisted so they
go through manual review
and then usually through manual review
they'll make sure it's the correct
subtitle that's but some of it is just
superstition
i don't know if that works i also have
places that i sit yeah for videos
posting
that's a bad spot for videos people were
curious in the comments why this is a
bad spot because the pokeman entered it
pokemon
wasn't it it just got demonetized yes
but but there's also been a few other
videos that i've sat
there and just watched the views tank so
i don't sit there no more
that's crazy i mean i see with the
algorithm i feel like everyone has their
suspicions like i don't schedule videos
oh you should i don't know i just leave
them there and then i set it public when
i want to
no i think um my theory too
and it's all superstition is that when
you schedule a video for a certain time
youtube
knows when that video is posting and can
better prep your audience and so like
sometimes i'll
notice that sometimes my views might
increase yeah before a video posts
i don't know if that's actually a thing
but uh i
i noticed that i think if you scheduled
your postings had a consistent schedule
where it's like every saturday
that's what i yeah but but every
saturday like 9am you post
okay and you monitor the title and
thumbnail within the first hour and if
it's any but you got to get a backlog
now videos to see like how
a good video does and doesn't do and if
you're
out of that range you got to change the
title of thumbnail okay yeah
you could probably double your views i
would say in probably 45 days
just by making those few changes but it
but it's going to require you to be
on it for the first hour after every
video post yeah and stick a schedule
stick with the schedule
i can definitely stick with the schedule
i feel like i've done that really well
from like saturdays and was like yeah
put it up go back to sleep
oh no no no never no no no my heart is
racing after every video that posts i am
like almost like
every day yeah oh yeah my heart races
every day
every day no at 9 00 am i stop
everything i'm doing
and i attended the video 3 30 i'll stop
whatever i'm doing i'll make my schedule
around the video posting so i could be
there for the posting it's a
yeah that first hour is a big deal do
you ever feel like you're running out of
ideas like every day making videos oh
yeah
all the time but somehow there's always
another idea and you just push through
it there's always something else
if yeah but yeah i think that's pretty
true yeah there's always something you
could say i'd be like oh
yeah i can maybe do that yeah right but
there are days i just don't want to make
a video and i just get upset
because it's it's i'm just not in the
mood that's the hardest thing but then
you kind of start and you're like this
isn't so bad
yeah so yeah i forced myself to start i
write it down
uh in my computer notepad i just say to
do today
plan a video and it means i have to make
that video so i don't have a choice it's
just like and it makes me feel better
knowing that at the end of the day
i'm gonna have a video planned out i
don't right now but it's gonna get done
so i feel better knowing that something
will be done
do you ever like take a break like a
vacation or not really no
no no no we don't we don't got time for
that no
no i'll take weekends do you have like a
goal with it like you're like
i want 10 million subscribers or
something that would be neat
uh 10 million really cool yeah i'd say
10 million subscribers
um no i i take vacations every now and
then macy and i would go to vegas
a few times so that would happen like
every other month um
i think we're planning something maybe
for labor day maybe catalina or
something
would be fun um on
it's hard to take more than like three
days because i'll have to prep
my videos ahead of time and like get
them all scheduled out i know you mean
that i've been like
contemplating getting this jaw surgery
because my bite has been messed
up forever and i've never wanted to do
it because i'm like things just come up
you know like
someone's wedding and then i can't make
videos for a month
but now i'm like the world's kind of
shut down i think i'm gonna do it
but i don't know how i'm gonna there's
never gonna there's never gonna be a
good time to do it and you could make it
i would make a video on the surgery i'm
definitely
gonna okay because i've watched a ton of
them because it's like
kind of intense and like i'm scared of
it but the videos help me feel like okay
this won't be
yeah i would do it you'll get a lot of
support you can make a video like going
into it and you could even make like a
mini series
and then at the end you do a full recap
from start to finish that's what i did
with the property
i introduced it the whole thing and then
very end one video summarizing the whole
thing
yeah i think i'm gonna have to because i
like won't be able to make any
other videos other than how much is the
surgery
you have to pay that out of pocket right
i'm guessing or no yeah most
people's insurance covers it because
it's medical it's not like cosmetic
it's like my bite's just so messed up
but i think because i waited
until i think if i got it when i was 18
it would have or the insurance i had
yeah
but it's like 20 000. my dad had that oh
really was it horrible
um it was about two months for him he
yeah his bite his bite was not aligned
properly
yeah and it was something that was
giving him headaches because i think
just like the way
yeah the way his teeth were like
grinding or chewing or something like
that it was giving headaches
so it was something that he needed to
get fixed
yeah yeah mine i don't really get
headaches but they said like later in
life i could and you really don't want
to get it
right then because it's way harder to
recover right but it's like
so hard to chew food when i got my
wisdom teeth out i was like
okay like three of my teeth collide
so this is not ideal um they said it can
like crack over time if you don't fix it
like your teeth can crack
i don't know get it get it fixed never a
good time to just schedule it do it get
have it october 16th so i'm trying to
pre-film before
there we go that's enough time to do
that yeah how many hours would you say
that you work per day
per day probably i guess it depends on
the day
like do we count this not real i don't
yeah i mean i well i count this
it's an obligation right yeah you would
i count this end to time yeah well i
feel like for me it's fun to go on
someone else's so
i guess not really how is your work
divided up like with hours and
how many hours you work per day i
usually start working on things at like
nine or ten and then i'll finish at like
six or seven unless it's the winter and
the sun's going down really early and
like the lighting is just really bad
sometimes i'll edit i'm just like i hate
working on things when it's dark out
i don't know like i will but i'd rather
just wake up early and do it but i'll
usually
wake up and work out and then when i'm
like fully ready
so yeah it ends up being i like working
nights sometimes well depends on the
night i've started uh
early morning schedule so six a.m it's
usually 6 p.m
i like that yeah but sometimes the
mornings from 6am to 9am sometimes
the best hours like i think the morning
is definitely the best
like i'll wake up and start editing
while i'm still like drinking coffee
yeah so it's like easy to do kind of fun
and then you're awake and like okay i
can film now that's how that's how i
feel or for me sometimes it's research
and planning in the morning and
i found from 6 a.m to maybe like 10 a.m
some some of the most creative hours
yeah i well i did the 6am thing like
before the quarantine i would wake up
and like i just joined equinox and so i
was like i'll go to a workout class
but it didn't last because everything
shut down
and then i was like yeah they put all
memberships on hold yeah yeah
like right after i joined i got a bench
and some free weights in the backyard
it's not the same i have a crazy setup
now really
it's called the tempo is that the mirror
it's actually different but i have the
mirror also okay so the tempo it's like
it's like the mirror but it's not a
mirror it's like a tv but it has
weights and it can track your form
that's cool but i'm doing a brand deal
with it so
i didn't pay for it but i love it oh
cool love the tempo there we go
how much would it be otherwise it's two
thousand dollars oh
wow okay well there you go even those
free weights are like 350
something like that for those adjustable
weights are so exciting and then
when when the illness struck people were
reselling like 600 bucks
that's still not safe i say it now no
no no that's another thing that'll
double your views just don't by not
saying i don't say i'm very
superstitious though with everything
do you find now in your real life you'll
be talking about when you're like the
pandemic the illness
i've done that and then i'm like sorry i
mean yes
you know all the time i just i i almost
don't say it now in real life
yeah same with same with swearing for me
uh in my early videos i wouldn't mind
swearing but i stopped swearing for
youtube
and now i never swear it's rare like for
me to say a bad word i feel just like
it's weird it feels unnatural now so
yeah i feel like i
kind of do in real life but not like a
crazy amount but if i'm editing a video
and i see myself because i'm like
yeah it doesn't look good no no no it
doesn't look good so take it out yeah
i wanted to talk about old youtube
because you've been posting for like 10
years
and you used to have a different name
than
shelby church right like when i very
first started what was the
something makeup oh yeah okay so when i
first started my channel it was when
youtube was like
usernames not really people's actual
names
and my sister was aerodynamic like all
we saw on youtube was people making
beauty videos and i was 14 so i thought
that was fun
um and so i did teen makeup tips because
i thought people were
probably searching for it did you
immediately
find success on youtube or did it take
you a while
it was i feel like pretty successful for
where youtube was at
then what year was that 2009.
wow okay yeah but i would just make
searchable videos like how to curl your
hair
how to i don't know reviewing random
stuff just kind of for fun
like they're really bad videos like
terrible
if you ever watch them do you go back
and watch those videos
i cannot watch oh that would be good
actually yeah um
i'll watch from the saturation era we
call it
the of the lifestyle youtubers there was
a time in like 2013 to
16 where everyone would just bump up the
saturation and do
the fakest videos like diy
valentine's day decor like random stuff
where it's like people don't
like make stuff for that yeah they're
making like five-minute crafts so
yeah or like a morning routine that's
just ridiculous
okay i don't know that stuff worked
really well at the time and then it
started to not and i was also like
i hate these videos and i feel like my
videos now are way more
real yeah they're way more i feel like
they're very cinematic and it's like
watching a 10
minute movie almost sometimes yeah it's
good it's good but i look at them i'm
like that takes so much time that's
that's all i think about is the time
yeah i actually i don't feel like it's a
waste of time because i don't think if i
made videos the way you do
i don't have the knowledge of that stuff
like people wouldn't care
i don't think so i don't know react
do one video try one reaction video to
me
title it my response to graham stefan
and
put very little effort this is something
you could knock out it's gonna be a test
yeah you could do the whole video from
start to finish in maybe
six hours start to finish challenge
acceptance post it seriously okay
as and just think if you want to make it
fancy just tell yourself don't
and just have a good time yeah just
title it might well you know the title
just a good thumbnail
yeah okay i'm going to try it yeah and
make it look like i'm like upset
sad steal one of my thumbnails like
where you want to make it look like
i did something to you i like you know
like a really a really good thumbnail on
the one the recent
reaction where i'm holding the nintendo
switch i was like that was from a
different video
that was luck i went through your
thumbnails i found that i'm like okay
that kind of fits
i saw that thumbnail i was like that's
that was really good
thanks now we put a lot of work into the
thumbnails it's worth it thank you yeah
so take one of my thumbnails put your
own spin on it just cut me out
put me on something else make me look
like the bag
you want people to think what did i do
to you okay like i
did something bad yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's so what i did i have a few
thumbnails where actually what i what
i've done is i take water
and put them in my eyes so it makes it
look like i'm crying and then in
photoshop i read my
oh my eyes it looks so intense um hold
on one sec
oh that one yeah yeah yeah
wow yeah so that was one that took me a
long time to do that
500 000 views i put water in my eyes
yeah and that was like 500 000 views a
year and a half ago
so yeah good video good thumbnail yeah
so just do that okay what do you
what do you think were some of the the
best or
most game-changing decisions that you've
made in your life
to put you in this current position that
you're in i
really think i've thought about this so
much getting a tesla i feel like i got a
whole new audience from that
it was like before kind of lifestyle
videos and trying to do tech stuff but
then when i got that it was like
now i have actually kind of a lot of guy
viewers which i never did before
and they kind of they've stuck around
for other videos which is
awesome did you always envision yourself
being an entertainer
not really i have envisioned myself more
behind the camera
like i wanted to like direct something
yeah i feel like
for since i was like 14 i knew i wanted
to do something
with video production it just so
happened to turn out to be youtube and i
feel like
people like look at youtube they look
down on it but it's so awesome because
we can do whatever videos we want we
don't have to pitch it to someone
and have it like the idea totally
changed
you know yeah just do whatever you want
that's what i like the freedom of
youtube
yeah because even if like a network were
to come and say like hey we'll give you
this deal
it's you wouldn't have that freedom
anymore you would have to report to
somebody
it goes against youtube yeah like i
still think it'd be cool to have like a
documentary series somewhere
but i'm i'm like i'm not hating youtube
at all you could just do that on youtube
and get more views on youtube than you
could from some tv networks yeah but i
think you
could if you made like a really good one
you could probably make more
like an hour-long documentary and i
don't know i feel like you might be able
to make more but i don't know
and just out of pure curiosity how have
cpm's changed over time
on youtube gotten so much higher it was
like a dollar when i first started
maybe 50 cents on some videos because i
bet advertisers didn't take it seriously
until maybe
three four years ago and even then even
now a lot of people just are like what
youtube
i can do that on youtube yeah who's
watching youtube
they have no idea it's still i think
it's still really cheap compared to
anywhere else oh yeah totally because
like
some of the videos that we'll make it's
so much effort to
at least mind them like putting a whole
week's worth of effort
making a brand deal but they're getting
the production of it
and the views when the amount they're
paying me they'd probably if they were
doing like a commercial they'd have to
pay like
a million dollars there was some
comparison i saw a while ago on youtube
oddly enough they compared the income of
a youtuber
with that of a like like an a-list
celebrity like a celebrity that was
getting the equivalent amount of views
youtubers making like a tenth of what
some of these celebrities like the
mainstream
tv movie celebrities were making even
though the youtuber was gaining just as
much traction online
so it's still cheap yeah that's kind of
it's like not super surprising but it's
weird yeah yeah it's just because
they have the the the what am i the
perspective of basically like because
she's in a movie
that makes them worth more than the
person who's on youtube doing the same
amount of views
yeah like people same eyeballs same
everything it's just i
so i think there's there's a ways to go
for youtube and just
online in general this could be very
stupid like how many people watch the
super bowl
versus how many people how many views
does like the average mr beast video oh
geez yeah exactly i don't know
like it's not half a million dollars for
a 30 second yeah and you got to think
about that too
well his demographic i i bet on the
super bowl is probably worth more
but they're doing the same views and
what what was it like two million
dollars for a 30-second spot
yeah yeah it was like it was like half a
million yeah at the minute
no it was two million dollars was it
yeah but it got a million bucks
we could be completely wrong the super
bowl could have like way more viewers
i'm just saying like
probably 100 million or something crazy
yeah yeah
wow okay 100 million viewers okay and mr
beast will get like 30 million
but i bet you like he's not making
nearly wow okay four and a half
million dollars for a 30-second slot hey
ramsay right 400 million dollars for 30
seconds
so you have to think if you just pass
back to back yeah so that means mr
beast's video should
be maybe about a million bucks when you
think his audience is not
as profitable i could see that if
someone's getting like 10 million views
a video
that should be worth that should be a
few hundred thousand dollars yeah
minimum i feel like if it's if you
average a million views a video i feel
like a brand deal should be like a
hundred thousand
yeah but they're not well it depends i
guess on the channel it can be it
depends on the channel of video but yeah
100 000 for a million views is kind of
gnarly i've heard of it i guess it
depends on the product and the channel
and what they're doing and how long of a
video and what the conversion rate would
be
with lifestyle channels for sure yeah
cool
all right well yeah it's pretty good do
you have anything you want to say
to the people still here oh my gosh um
i don't think buying starbucks is that
bad so with that said you guys thank you
so much for watching shall be a link to
all of your information down below in
the description
where you can get your two free stocks
by using the link
one of those stocks have you done this
yet one of the stocks is worth up to one
thousand four dollars
weeble i have done that oh there you go
so
you should do that too i'll link to all
of your information in the description
stay tuned for my response oh yeah
responding to graham stefan
yeah and uh hit the like button
subscribe if you have not done that
already
um yeah yeah cool
you so much for watching and until next
time till next time oh
you got to say yeah you got to say smash
the like button smash the like button if
you want to if you felt like this was
worth it
smash it regardless
the cat's gonna go crazy at some point
okay
he has his like excited spurts so when
he does he's like
zoomies like a dog yeah yeah exactly so
when he does that that's usually when we
have to stop
briefly i'll go kind of crazy there we
go so welcome oh wait wait
i'll talk to this one okay cool
so what what episode is it 15.